yeah tell me about
um Mr Beast he like is is so unique in
the fact that he is laser focused in a
way that I've never really experienced
and and maybe at times like in in a way
that I don't want to experience yeah
yeah so he doesn't want to know
[Music]
Colin and I you know spent a lot of our
career making documentaries and what we
noticed was like if we were interviewing
a subject and we were just interviewing
them head on we wouldn't get good
answers and then we started taking them
like driving or have them do something
else and then you would get the truth
it was really interesting it's like the
truth comes out in the car I think it's
something that uh some documentarians
say where it's like if someone's doing
something else they're much more open if
their mind isn't 100 on right the
interview uh why is that you think
they're just performing basically when
they sit down in a like a artificial
environment probably yeah there's a lot
of like self
perception stuff that's going on right
it's like how am I coming across who am
I is the sounding right and if you're
distracted then you but you guys do your
interviews at a table basically yeah so
you don't do that well we've been trying
to explore like the concept of creating
the right energy for the conversations
right yeah like you think about like
this has a completely different energy
than if there was a table has a
completely different energy than if we
didn't have mics and we were laughed or
had booms
so we've been trying to explore like
where our show is moving and what type
of space we want that's essentially
exactly where I wanted to start which is
basically you guys do so we came down
here and we were like oh let's get like
a place let's have some in-person
interviews with people that we think are
awesome and uh it's different than the
like at home thing for sure right the
vibe is different you get a different
energy but also you can do like
high stakes interviews almost it's like
the whole day kind of gets built around
this interview which is not really the
case we do it online and
um you guys have been doing some high
stakes interviews so you're doing stuff
with uh I mean just recently I just saw
the Tim Ferriss one that was great and
I'm guessing you're like me that you
grew up kind of like really into Tim
ferriss's stuff and you know kind of
admire him yeah it was pretty surreal
that's a that's a high stakes interview
you did Mr Beast you did dream we did a
bunch of these things first do you
prefer
like being the interviewee or in this
case you're kind of like more the guest
on the on the show do you prefer guest
or host I like to talk so like I like
when we are the host and it is a
conversation I think that's the most fun
for me like I do I am a naturally
curious person and you know along with
higher Stakes it's also like very very
interesting people that I'm inherently
curious about right so that to me is
really fun I think where it's you know
where it gets challenging is if you
don't have chemistry but we actually now
do pre-calls and kind of not like
chemistry reads but we try and gauge
yeah what our chemistry is with the with
the guest because we've been in
situations where the chemistry is not
good and then you're like
okay how do I like where do we go from
here how does this work uh and and when
you're the producer of the show or it's
your show in the middle of it you're
like okay is this gonna perform voice in
your head how do I edit this how does it
and that then puts you into a hole like
a disadvantage yeah you're so let's say
you're doing one of these kind of like
interviews you're pumped for uh I'll
call it a high stakes interview yeah how
do you kind of walk me through how
you're preparing for that and how you're
like just kind of like getting ready to
perform that yeah yeah actually we've
been really trying to establish our
relationship with prep because we found
that sometimes if we're overly prepped
I'm barely listening to the other person
I just know where I'm going talking
point yeah I know where I'm going
um and also how much of them I listened
to Prior because if I know their stories
I know they're beats I'm kind of like
right you know a bit curiosity yeah the
Curiosity Wayne so
um been trying to explore that
relationship we do have it like we have
a team that essentially develops a
research dockly with someone on our team
who does that he's like here's here's
kind of like some origin story and we we
structure it like a act one act two act
three structure where where is their
origin story what's the inflection point
right where has that put them today
right because it's like what was the
tense part of the journey what what
didn't work for them do we know any of
that is there something we can ask about
that creates an inflection point because
we are trying to tell a story with it
yeah so we need to know the general
themes of what's happening in the origin
right the Act One what's happening in
the conflict the Act 2 and then the
resolution and the future right
um so that's like the most outgoing all
the details without knowing all the
details yeah
um so yeah we're trying to establish a
new relationship with that of how much
is it like curiosity and how much is it
prep uh and I think that's become
more substantial for us as the landscape
of interview shows is getting more and
more saturated right like when we
interviewed
um you know certain creators three years
ago
no one else was interviewing creators so
it was kind of like okay this is a talk
show for our own Community right it
doesn't exist anywhere else now we're a
part of a group and that then pushes you
to try and become more singular and more
differentiated and chemistry how you
show up who the hosts are matters right
I think you guys have done actually a
really good job of that I think about
your show a lot because I think tell me
more what are we doing well well I think
you have to be it's similar because
there's two hosts right
um which is really hard which is really
hard in interviews but probably you have
a better reception when it's just you
and Sam yeah on a lot right it's like
when you're building a show that's guest
dependent
um or all about the guest bookings it's
like some people will look at this and
be like I don't know who that is so I'm
not going to click on it some people
give it a chance because they trust you
um but really if if it's you and Sam you
can carry the show and then you become
less reliant on
booking so I do think like Colin and
I've been thinking a lot about that how
do we instill some of that how do we
think about that but we are just like
the show takes us to really interesting
people like Tim Ferriss and so right now
in this moment yeah you keep writing it
like this is cool the type of Outreach
we have is really cool the people we get
to talk to is really cool so you said
something like uh how do I show up yeah
um I think about this a lot because
when it comes to like sports we're used
to an athlete having like a pre-game
routine immediately nap a stretch thing
a warm-up they're wearing the headphones
they're listening to their song yeah
they get the motivational speech they
run up they run out there they do the
warm-ups and then they play yeah and but
for other types of people who need to
perform
it's like what are you doing why do you
need to do that just sit down and talk
right it seems so easy it's definitely
presence like you have to become very
present right in the conversation and so
there's there's a couple different
things to to try to do that for me
personally I've discovered this 11
minute Wim Hof breath work nice online
that's it I think it's brutal I do that
a lot have you done it yeah yeah there's
so many people who know this exact one
it's like 11 minutes it's like it's free
YouTube like top ranked YouTube and he's
his accent is amazing come on all right
guys yeah it's so good uh and like that
just gets me in the zone like I love
that thing I want to do that right now
oh my gosh yeah do you do it laying down
yeah or do you do it laying down that's
his way on your back so we made a
documentary about whim years ago and so
like I've just been which one I've never
seen it it's uh it's on yes Theory's
channel it's all called Frozen alive
Colin and I actually edited it okay
um yes yes
this is it it's so good so good yeah so
lie down sit down whatever it takes by
the way this is good as a like uh I do
this like whenever I have like a team
Retreat or like we need to do something
um I'll be like hey guys like if you're
if you're down let's do something a
little bit weird and then yeah their boy
like what is he gonna say and this is
not so weird they're down with it and
you you definitely feel energized right
at the end of it yeah I just try and get
present like I try and take out a lot of
the variables I think as we've built a
team what's been great is like it used
to be me and Colin being like okay where
do the mics go where do the cameras go
does the lighting look good
um and that can be really stressful yeah
I mean for example our most recent
interview with Mr Beast when we went out
to North Carolina
you know we were there for a full day
prepping for the Pod but at the last
minute realized we didn't have a table
and Colin and I went to a furniture
store in North Carolina two hours before
we sat down with him and we're just
scrambling to buy a table and then
assemble it had to arrange for it to be
delivered and basically it all happened
within a matter of you know that was a
very stressful two hours prior to
sitting down and I felt very not present
in the first half of that right you know
I was I was just coming off like okay
that that was intense why didn't I think
of that kind of immediately already
being retrospective of the process of
you know and so all of that stuff I
think you just have to eliminate I made
a bunch of mistakes like that when uh
this this podcast started with me doing
long form interviews like the first 20
episodes was just me interviewing people
at a studio and whatever and I I kind of
like got reps there and then it switched
at like I don't know episode something
40 or something like that to me and Sam
as like a recurring thing which was like
way different prep you know TurnKey
TurnKey set up already have good
chemistry
um don't have to book gas don't have to
research cast just like being ready to
talk about interesting things and like
just turn up the the sort of Charisma as
much as you can but now that I got back
into
being like all right let's try to like
we have this amazing Network these are
Fascinating People to talk to let's just
let's do it and I I told Ben I called
Ben after the first one I was like
dude that was like an hour too long
because I did three hours I was like I
thought I was Joe Rogan for a minute
there I did three hours way too long
um and then I was like I over prepped
like crazy and the thing you were saying
where you're like yeah I'm listening but
in my head I'm like okay I'm supposed to
be to this next I was like that wasn't
right and so it's hard before this we
went to Dave and Buster's in between
interviews and uh you know played Papa
shot and I got in a good good Zone and
now I'm here it's either that or Wim Hof
you know Dave mustard yeah if you don't
have a local Dave and Busters if you're
unfortunate enough I thought you're
gonna say if you don't have a local
women yeah you always got whim
um you've had a bunch of these yes who's
somebody that's been a lot of fun uh
that you guys have had on recently
that's like you know giving you those
kind of like mind-blown brains leaking
out my ear like who's done that for you
recently yeah it's hard to not say Tim
um Tim Ferriss school but tell me what
was dope about the Tim one with Tim it
was the fact that he's been doing this
for so long and and um he really opened
my eyes to this concept of having a very
high quality audience and I look at Tim
and I think he has like an incredibly
high quality audience
um and I think we make a lot of
sacrifices because we distribute our
stuff on YouTube for viewership right
right like it is it's very odd that we
have public performance metrics next to
our work there's very few other places
where that happens right like in
business it doesn't happen where you're
like here's how well I'm doing and
anyone can see that at any time if you
go to a Shopify store it doesn't just
show you sales yeah how many sales has
this have exactly the truest rawest like
Benchmark imagine walking into a grocery
store and it just has like you know
Revenue under every product it's just
it's a very odd thing that pushes us to
make decisions for larger viewership
rather than higher quality of your
ownership and I think sitting with Tim
uh it was a deep understanding of how
he's built a very high quality premium
audience and a premium brand over a
decade and I think he said something in
that interview to you he was like
um there's always a market for like the
best the best yeah and he's like so I
wanted whatever the ads were priced at I
was gonna go like double that and be
like that's how do I get that to be the
thing because that will always be there
there will always be a market for
whoever's got the highest quality
audience with the best ad read you know
that's that'll always be there and I
think that's played out yeah and I think
uh what's important is to for us as
creators just to realize like what we
are doing is not novel it's been done
before we're building audiences we're
media companies you know this has been
done before and we should look far back
at who's done it really well yeah you
know and I I think that sitting with Tim
was that opportunity and you know almost
as a self-fulfilling prophecy like the
type of people who reached out to us
after the Tim episode really was
emblematic of it is a high quality
audience that watches Tim and that's
interested in him it was not our highest
performing episode right but it's one of
my favorite and it's one that drove a
lot of high quality Outreach right and
it reminded me of that of of we can get
really caught up in you know High
viewership but I think that was
something that that really pushed me in
there's a lot of stuff in there there's
something that I never forget that he
said which was um if you do something
that is even slightly energy depleting
it will compound over time
um and to like really look at your
day-to-day and recognize what is
depleting your energy because it'll
compound everything when you say that
it's like I feel like everybody can
think of like the one thing right away
yeah that you haven't been like really
paying that much attention to but when
prompted your brain is like of course
it's this yeah and this is you know this
is four hour work week from his book but
he talked a lot about who are the right
clients to have like what you know money
is not we look at it as such like well
it's a lot of money so I'll sacrifice
these things for it but if if the client
relationship isn't good if it's
depleting your energy if it's causing a
strain on your team it's not worth it
and all those viewpoints are almost
antithetical to our
the internet age of us being like all of
this is infinite right you know we can
always be making more money we should
always be pursuing more viewership More
Money More Of Everything uh he came in
with the perspective of what's the right
money what's the right right
so he said that energy depleting thing
what did you think of for you I thought
of um
like meetings yeah I'm like a creative
person I like to be creative and I've
kind of just spun myself up to be like
we run a media company so I need to
operate like a media company owner and
like I think about hosting meetings or
being on Zoom calls and I'm like I
I really don't like it right at all so
on the podcast once did a really funny
rant where he was like you know he's
like long build up he was like you know
I've been uh you know we sold the hustle
this many months ago it's been six
months I've talked to this person this
person I thought about all these things
you know what I realized
I'm a [__] artist man and I was like
it's not what you think is coming when
he when he says it and he also doesn't
like like he doesn't come across like an
artist like some people that the way
they dress what they do you're like
that's an artist yeah and he's like I'm
a [__] artist man I just need to
create and I'm going to keep doing that
no matter what the situation is I I
should have they said be an investor I
tried I don't want to do that I don't
want to do that [__] you know I stopped
doing it all together I just want to be
an artist and uh I think about that a
lot actually I think there's like a a
great way to like kind of draw a line in
the sand around like you know what this
is what I am because it gives me a bunch
of energy and like what is what is that
not like you know and how do I just not
have to do it maybe I don't have to do
it at all I think sometimes I I operate
from an old model with a new business
where you know I grew up my dad's an
entrepreneur from an Indian immigrant
family like
it was all about going to his office you
know clocking in the morning clocking
out like being there every day being
present uh in front of your team and I
think we're just in a new world where
it's like is that do I need to operate
like that as a creative as a Creator
um I I found myself that another thing
that Tim said was it was a quote from
Whitney Cummings but he said if art
imitates life then you have to have a
life
and I think that the the mentality of
like I really want to succeed is hey I'm
going to go to my office I'm going to
grind every day I'm going to work really
hard but then as a creative person or as
someone who's on a podcast it's like
well now I have very little experiences
to talk about or you know it's kind of
like I can tell you about the coffee
shop down the street from here where I
get coffee every day and then I come and
sit here all day right I'm so routine
yeah listen to this why does anyone want
to listen to if I don't have interesting
life experiences there's um uh a thing I
realized which was my my grandfather uh
like what does your grandfather do or
one of your grandfathers like did they
like have like a factory job or like any
like yeah my grandfather that I knew
because the other one uh passed before I
was born
um had a um like train engineering job
in India yeah almost exactly the same
like grandfather some engineering like a
chemical plant right of some kind he
worked there and like to him work was
you come to the factory where the the
ingredients are coming in they're
getting processed there's fumes
everywhere and like that's what work is
and there's like a shift supervisor yeah
and then
if he saw what my dad did which was like
go to work with a briefcase there's a
computer on your desk you sit in a like
kind of cubicle or desk like oh sorry
office and you know you take phone calls
or you get on a flight and go to a
business meeting where you're gonna
shake a hand and maybe do a paper
contract deal like that was kind of my
dad's job that's like what work became
right it's just kind of unrecognizable
and looks much less serious than the
chemical plant or the the fertilizer
Factory or whatever yeah
um and then like to my dad what I do
he's like are you ever gonna work like
what are you doing you're sitting in
front of your phone uh you know you're
talking to who who's listening to this
you get paid for this like well if I
give a bunch of views then yes or like
you know sometimes you know if that's
like I'm I'm working it's like no you're
just [__] around on YouTube it's like
right that's exactly what I do I like
I'm looking for in the most interesting
things in the world and I'm synthesizing
and I'm gonna talk about it but it's
like our version of work is unrest
unrecognizable too like you know our
parents and I'm like oh like I just have
uh kids and I just have two two little
kids I'm like whatever they're gonna do
is probably gonna blow my mind it's
gonna be so super unrecognizable it's
super unrecognizable but every
generation does that I'm like oh that's
kind of interesting like I should kind
of not write off those things that look
like complete not work yeah um and like
our company got bought by twitch which
is like if you watch people playing
video games for a living it's like what
this has not work that was a very
confusing era I mean even now at you
know in my mid-30s when I look at what a
20 year old Creator is doing it's hard
for me to track uh you know I I spend a
lot of time on YouTube I spend a lot of
time talking YouTube creators but this
next wave of creators is kind of like
wait what's happening what's going on um
what's the name of that girl who's like
going viral because she's like a NPC
doll yeah baby doll yeah I was like that
that's like yeah is that the thing I
don't know is that what our kids are
going to do they're gonna breaking
machine all of this is so like uh it
brings so much about like who are we as
people like right what is that that
we're into uh have you seen this thing
it's really strange have you seen Pinkie
doll basically she's she's just standing
there and like people are donating using
the tick tock live thing have you guys
seen this yeah there it is
so good thank you Jackie gang gang gang
gang gang gang oh special gang gang
gang gang gang gang balloon
if they donate the cowboy she always
says the same thing the same way like uh
like she's a bot and she's just making
like I don't know like whatever she's
making like seven thousand dollars a day
seven thousand dollars
there's all these funny memes too of
like uh guys filming their girlfriend
like doing this
I think it says a lot about what we
crave as audiences obviously there's
like a lot there to unpack of what we're
into but um the interactivity like you
think back to entertainment
um even when we were growing up it was
like the TV told you what was on it was
a lean back experience right turn on TV
if what you wanted wasn't on you just
waited and you may not even know yeah
you know you're super into these like
Niche cooking shows right until the yeah
until chopped comes out and you're like
oh exactly I didn't know I wanted to
watch other people cook but I don't know
if you remember the TV Guide channel
yeah it was a TV Guide channel you just
waited told you what was on channel 12
and if you missed it you had to wait a
whole nother 100 channels scrolled by so
that was like a very lean back
experience where we're like okay you
tell us what's what to watch right
um and then as we progressed there was
like TiVo and it was more on demand it's
like oh [__] we can record a show and
like have it on demand or see what's
coming up
um and now you accelerate it all the way
to YouTube or Instagram and it's like I
can search for what I want I can curate
my own entertainment now it's I can
create my own entertainment right right
I can pay money and she will do
something yes that's like in that's the
next level right it's like interactive
entertainment where I'm not consuming it
I'm creating the entertainment I'm part
of making part of it yeah yeah and I
think that's what you know twitch I
think is a great example of that too
right like people people watching long
live streams why it's because they can
have an impact on it yeah I think people
don't really even actually understand
what's going on with twitch um like now
I think it's accepted that twitch is a
thing which took a while to be like is
that like a big deal and it's like yeah
it's actually a pretty big deal but I
think unless you use twitch I think
people still sort of think um the
default is probably like
uh twitch is people watching other
people with Video Games Live and so
maybe they're really good at the game
it's like yeah that's part of it but
then some people are you know like
a lot of people are just there for the
chat a lot of people are just using this
background noise in another tab like I
remember looking at some data when we
were there about how many people are
literally just that's not the focused
tab on Chrome
and some people were like well we should
we should like discount that as like you
talk to users like no that's like how I
like to use twitch I'm not just yeah
it's not like at an accident and it's
just running in the background like I
listen to it while I work and I'm coding
and I'm listening to this and I'll check
back in like every every time something
interesting happening I'll go I hear the
crowd War basically I go look at the
score and I go see what's going on to me
it's like the reinvention of the radio
right twitch has right really operated
like that but then again where you get
to play a part in it Ludwig was another
creator that we we talked to on the show
where he has developed this kind of
adversarial relationship with his chat
yeah because the way you said it was
interesting you go it's kind of boring
if everybody's if this else is just
supportive right yeah it's like you're
right and I was like I never really
thought of it that way
um and he's not adversarial like they
hate each other how would you describe
it like what is what's an example of
like what's going on on his channel it
is so odd there's so many different
things that go on I would say his
sub-a-thons are probably the thing to to
bring into Focus which is essentially
you know he'll go live for he he
initially started as 24 hours but
um every time you uh subscribe every new
subscriber he extended it right so
essentially yeah
it was an adversary right it was like I
want this to end but when you take this
action it extends right right it extends
an hour so he ended up doing it for 30
days uh Straight live streaming to 30
days straight but again now but yeah it
was fun while it lasted but that's an
example of like having an adversary
relationship which which is you know
kind of like you can interact but you're
bringing me discomfort right you know by
by doing this
um so it makes it fun for the audience
to to play with that and it's obviously
like a joking relationship yeah but
there's something that's you know fun
about that and I think we should really
think about these audiences the young
audiences that are growing up with this
what do they want next right because we
are
we are thinking about like the
advancements of of entertainment in the
context of what we had and how advanced
this is that we can self-publish on the
internet right and that people can
comment and we can have Discord servers
and we can engage with them but there's
there's a whole nother you know version
of participation even think about Tick
Tock like why do why did Tick Tock
become such a big thing it's
participation it's like it was easy to
participate for anybody to make it yeah
it's easy to and they told you what to
do right here's the trend here's the
dance here's the dance here's how you do
it here's 100 videos of people doing it
here's the sound you try click this you
try it now right yeah so the the even
you look at Pinkie doll right what we're
just talking about for you to do that
for you or I to start doing that it's we
just start a live account that's it we
just start like there's the
participation is so easy
um where we can either participate in
the actual live stream or become that
Creator within a matter of minutes right
uh what do you think's next where do you
see the putt going with that obviously
hard to predict it's hard to predict but
I think anyone could it might be you
yeah but I think I think what we have to
realize is that
um Tick Tock taught us a lot about the
fact that the platform is the creator uh
in that context right like if you take
the top 10 creators off of tick tock
Tick Tock still Tick Tock right you
still open it and you it's a For You
page you wouldn't even notice it's
almost reverting back to the lean back
experience I opened Tick Tock and I say
you tell me what's going on right back
to what we were just talking about with
TV it's just that it's personalized to
every single person yeah so it's hyper
personalized I think is number one right
when we think about the trends that are
that are coming which is already
happening but I think also
um
like participation forward so it's like
it's personalized but it's really easy
for me to engage in the action too and I
think that's where maybe there's like
two extremes there's the the Mr Beast
where it's like I can't do I can't buy a
train and have it go into a ditch which
is something he did in this last video
and then the opposite end of the
spectrum is like here's what's happening
on YouTube shorts or or Tick Tock and
actually really easy for me to do that
and I can try it myself I'm in s I'm in
San Francisco
if you walk around SF you uh you know
you can't like you know you you stub
your toe it's like what did I step on oh
AI it's like nothing is right the answer
to everything is AI
and I kind of wonder if the answer to
this is also AI meaning you see that AI
can draw amazing art I like a pink you
know it can paint better than right you
know a human can paint it can paint
anything you want instantly whatever
um it can write it can make you know
chat GPT can make rap lyrics and so I
wonder
you know how do we just get to the point
where actually the Creator is the
algorithm is the creator it's just it's
hyper personalized and here's just like
it's gonna just deep fake and create
something that it thinks you like and
it's just gonna try 10 000 variations
per second and then if anything starts
to work it starts to like go more down
that rabbit hole for for more creators
yeah it might not even be a Creator it
might just be self-generating video
right that's what I mean yeah
okay people seem to like because they
have I mean an unreal amount of data
right they're like people like to hear
people eat that's like you and Sam been
defect yet have you heard of my first
million yeah I've heard of uh Audio Only
not a video one but an audio only
version that's a fake conversation and
how how close I mean it's like
like okay if somebody listened to if my
family member who doesn't listen to the
Pod listen to it they would just think
this is the podcast yeah because it
doesn't sound robotic right there's
little moments but it's like kind of
passable if you don't know what deep
fakes are you'd be like I guess it just
sounded like that if you listen to the
Pod you'd be like oh you're cool but
you're not really like substantively
saying anything like did you hear the
one where they did Joe Rogan talking to
Steve Jobs yeah and that one was pretty
good I think we kind of edited it well I
know my cool demo I listened to Joe
Rogan and Sam Altman is which is it's a
YouTube channel called The Joe Rogan AI
experience and I genius idea yeah it's a
genius idea but I clicked on it to find
out like Joe Rogan and Sam Altman
um talking about open Ai and how Chachi
PT Works Right started listening to it
to be like what does this sound like I
want to hear one and then
I just was like wait this is just good
and interesting and then I just found
myself listening to it and then I was
like do I care so if we can do that with
the like V 0.1 then you just have to
believe like okay inevitably that's
where it goes there's been a few of
these that go viral right like the kind
of AI uh fake AI things like there's one
on Twitch I don't know if you've seen
the twitch one of Biden and Trump
debating yes I think where we're gonna
see this all really skyrocketed is
during the election for sure yeah right
and it's gonna get really weird crazy
and weird
um I brought it up about you because
um it happened to me and Colin recently
where it was a video of me Colin and Mr
Beast talking about an online casino
that he had started and it was also our
lips were also right um and there's it
on YouTube or no it's taken down we got
it taken down
um we got to take him down pretty fast
but yeah it's cool [__] that yeah it was
really compelling but I mean it it was
too compelling like people could click
on it it's like to the to just the
untrained eye it's like oh that could
have been a moment from the podcast I
didn't watch
um I've had to have conversations with
my parents about like
hey careful be careful if someone calls
you and you think it's me let's develop
like a safe word basically
um with all this like when you ask me
what's next the thing that's been on my
mind the most is physical experiences
okay I actually think that we're gonna
want things that are uniquely human
um in the coming years I think we're
going to want things that are like
Collective human experiences where right
like stand-up comedy I think we were
going to want to sit and be like that
human is standing there delivering that
entertainment to me or plays in theater
um I think we're gonna want that and I
think there's a lot of digital creators
who are building really
promising communities where people will
show up but a lot of online creators who
are building High viewership but no one
would actually show up to something that
they do and I think that's and what's
the difference
I think the difference is
um
the amount of Personality that you
inject into your videos and if people
are willing to connect with that right
like long-form podcasting is there's
people who spend more time with you and
Sam than they do talking to their own
mom right or their their own best friend
so they have this like really in-depth
parasocial relationship you guys have
done Live Events people come yeah right
um and I think there's other creators
who rip all of that out because they're
looking at the algorithm and they're
like you know what when I inject my
personality right 10 of people stop
watching but they're looking at it on a
view of like five million people and
they'd rather have five million views
than 4.5 million views but when I look
at it I'm like I think I'd rather have a
hundred thousand views or a hundred
thousand dedicated fans who are who walk
away knowing something about it one more
unit of trust who are who are down to
listen to me talk and and understand my
personality then try and rip all of that
out to make sure they get to the end of
the video and that is that is how like
the business YouTube is is predicated on
do they click and do they watch till the
end but I think sometimes that can give
you the wrong signals of
what should I keep in what should I keep
out right and again back to the
conversation of high quality audience
um and I think the young creators it's
like it's like playing video games on
YouTube right if I try this then this
number goes up right right and I think
that is too easy to manipulate right now
um and there's there's so much
information I think we're we're part of
that of like sharing information on how
that all works but you do have to take a
step back and be like am I building a
brand
and a brand is about trust credibility
depth of connection and that comes from
some stuff that might not be optimized
for the algorithm yeah there's um it's
sort of like Drop Shipping versus like
building an actual brand around what you
do right like that's good there's um I
don't know if you ever saw when Sony got
hacked do you remember that one yeah
there was one email that I remember came
out that was like pretty interesting and
I think it was
um one of the early Sony guys talking to
the CEO and he was or one of the it
wasn't maybe the early Center guys maybe
it was like one guy from like a like a
music a record label
talking to him and he was like you know
here's what we're seeing and he's like
basically the more popular this gets
like you know people streaming music at
home blah blah he's like it's also
creating a pent-up demand for what he
calls I think I think out of home
entertainment's gonna be big and he's
like out of home entertainment like uh
he's like festivals will do well this
was like a while back and like there was
like this kind of like pretty big Music
Festival craze that kind of came out of
it
um but there was also a couple other
like trends like that like even things
like Tough Mudder and Spartan Race all
of a sudden people were like you know
what I just want to like go and
voluntarily crawl through mud this
weekend right like why would somebody
want to do that it's like yeah kind of
because you're sitting in front of a
computer all day yeah life got too easy
and you kind of feel soft inside to go
voluntarily have this like hardship but
also you want to be able to Instagram it
and put it online who that you did it
yeah I think uh I totally agree with
that and I mean obviously that that it
that's what happened but I think AI is
going to create like this homogeneous
nature to content right everything's
gonna feel the same aim and that is
going to make us create something
completely unique and different almost
like looking for like AI has brought a
lot of efficiencies into our studio
um we use AI for a lot like what do you
guys use autopod are you familiar with
that no what are they okay so there's
there's three cameras right now right
and so basically you would bring these
three cameras in and you want to get a
Clarity on like if I'm talking the
cameras on me if you're talking the
cameras on you oh it does those cuts it
just does those cuts automatically it's
a three hour conversation it'll do it in
90 seconds oh that's amazing and it'll
be very precise when you start talking
it'll go there if you have a human here
live switching which I don't know if
someone's watching he's not live right
now but we talked about it like right
before we started I guess so if he's
live switching with the switcher he
actually can't predict when you're about
to start talking right he's gonna be a
second late so now I do I trust the
human more or do I trust the AI more I
mean the reality is it's brought a ton
of efficiency into our office that's
cool we also explore YouTube titles and
play around with AI to be like hey
here's the title we thought of but give
us 10 variations right and sometimes
maybe it's it's ours that we like right
but if we keep going down that path you
know the other day we were in this chat
GPT or it's a different tool chat GPT
but there's there's other like Creator
specific AI tools there's some that
aren't public
um that can only be used if you're uh
partnered with certain you know Creator
companies specifically uh there's a
company called spotter yeah that has a
really great uh AI tool that I was using
this morning and the funny thing is like
you're sitting in a room with with your
team and
it's is it more efficient to sit alone
with AI and get hundreds of variations
or is it is it more efficient to sit
together as a team for 30 minutes I
don't know the answer to that but I
think probably it's AI right
um so the question for me is like if
this if it's driving so much efficiency
I think I'm gonna Crave inefficiency in
other places and right it's like the
slow food movement totally like from the
table exactly fast food gets too present
yeah it creates the demand the craving
for the other for the inefficiencies
yeah I've what I've seen though is that
even though that gets created
it does usually end up getting dwarfed
by the thing that of course uh you know
yeah better better faster cheaper you
know like yeah style of stuff
entertainment I think is different
like
you go to a concert it's the most
inefficient way to hear the music right
the Taylor Swift concert right you if
you like Taylor Swift music and you just
want to hear it just go on Spotify right
you're one tap away so why do you want
this collective experience why do you
want to drive deal with parking get in
there you know get to your seat it's
kind of a pain in the ass to go to a
concert right so what is it about that
that's you know it's a it only happens
once right it's like an experience that
you get to happen but you know by the
Numbers a lot more people will stream
Taylor Swift and we'll go to that agree
but you know she'll make a lot of money
and monetize totally uh totally
differently yeah tell me about um Mr B
so I've gotten to go to his place and
hang out with him a little bit pretty
remarkable dude
um
and not like oh he's like an alien or
whatever but just like very interesting
to kind of see him in his like normal
ways uh of working and you can kind of
see some differences between how he
approaches things like you know for me I
was like oh
how does he approach things how does he
see situations and approach things
differently than I do and he came on the
Pod but it actually was like nothing he
said on the Pod would have given me that
Insight but actually watching him work
and like kind of being in a brainstorm
with him then you do start to see those
differences I think you've gotten a lot
of access to those moments yeah what's
uh what stood out to you that you've
kind of like picked up or noticed just
by spending a little time with him I
always say he's like the most unique
human I have ever met uh I think he's
like very very unique in what he cares
about you know I think what he cares
about is very different from you know
what I care about or what a lot of
people care about he's different what
does he hear about
he like is is so unique in the fact that
he is laser focused in a way that I've
never really experienced and and maybe
at times like in in a way that I don't
want to experience yeah yeah so he
doesn't want to no I mean him and I have
this conversation a lot like I I don't
crave what he has
um I like to have more of a wide
perspective on life and a view of uh
different types of experiences and he's
very
um committed to his craft and very like
he he can laser focus in on something
like if you've been in one of those
brainstorms with him he's just like very
blunt he's very you know he's just like
why would we do that that doesn't make
sense like no doesn't it doesn't exist
in the same way for him that it exists
for other people based on social context
or based on like well I guess he said no
doesn't exist for him yeah the same way
it exists for other people I think
that's really accurate yes I have a
story of an example of that many stories
the time where I saw the most was at the
Mr Beast Burger opening in New Jersey at
the American dream Mall Colin and I was
insane right we spent the 24 hours with
him before and after
um and lived with him through this like
what felt like a uh hurricane storm of
fandom and new experiences for him and
Reed and the whole team did you think it
was going to be go to the part where
where he walks out where he walks out
dude that was so I was the only camera
behind him at that moment
is famous but I was like this is not
what I thought was gonna no I mean
there's multiple times where I had the
chills filming this video
um so I filmed I filmed that clip and
then Jimmy was like that's crazy send me
that and I sent it to him and then he
tweeted it and it was just like it's
completely insane um but so that
experience There Was You know the night
before there was a question around like
how many burgers they could serve and
and there's already I think you know 15
or 20 000 people
there the night before right it was
completely insane and uh they were
sleeping in the Mall mall security was
there and they were just like okay all
right I guess
no I don't think anyone fully understood
uh how big he was at that moment
um and so they were like okay we don't
know if we can serve all these people
and Jimmy was just like what what do you
mean let's just figure it out like what
do we need to do and they're like it's
just not possible we can't get more
supplies here and he was like well can
can we pay for it can we just pay
someone to do it and he was like well I
don't you know I don't think so I don't
think that's possible and basically what
ended up happening was it was possible
and Jimmy just kept pushing right at a
point where again it's like a lot of
people would be like okay that's a no if
I ask three times yeah yeah there's no
other Possible Oh the fire marshal said
it yeah whatever yeah and I think he he
thinks in different ways too of like um
you know the his immediate thought was
around the staff he was like I need the
staff to be
really into this I need them to be on it
and so he's like I'm gonna pay everyone
an extra thousand dollars today and that
is thirty thousand there's 30 people
working it was thirty thousand dollars
and it's in our video where he says I'm
gonna pay all of you guys an extra
thousand dollars to whatever you're
getting paid today right
um that's like an irrational thing to do
a lot of people would look at that and
be like that's kind of irrational
um to spend an additional thirty
thousand dollars
um but you know he looks at that and he
was like this is what I need to make
this excellent right we're just gonna do
that you know and you look at what he
tweets about now too he spends you know
a million or two million dollars on a
video and it makes 200 000 in AdSense
revenue and you know obviously his
sponsors and stuff but some of his
videos don't make money and and he's
just like but that's they're good right
you know he he thinks in just different
ways like that yeah just very unique I
uh yeah I feel the same way he also
um said some things so he also said some
things that were like really funny to me
like um he was like I was like so do you
want to like have kids or like what's
your like what do you want out of life
beside okay yeah I've heard the YouTube
part and I was like what else do you
want I think he said he was like I want
to be president I want to do this I want
to be a billionaire and I was like okay
cool but like what do I just like out of
your life like forget the big cool
sounding things like do you want to get
married have kids like what do you want
to do and he was like um
he's like yeah you know I uh he's like
yeah I'll I think I'll probably like you
know date or get married or whatever
he's like Isaac I wouldn't want kids no
[__] no I don't want kids and I was like
oh why not he's like oh he's like
actually
you know like Steve and Elon they have
kids there's probably something to it so
I'll do it and I was like our first just
hilarious to be like uh like yeah just
like the first thing basically literally
like the dead Steve Jobs you never met
and be like he's just like that's that's
the class of people I'm in yeah you know
if those people did it might be
something to it so I'll do it just kind
of for that reason but I don't feel the
need for that because I'm on this
Mission and like you know that's where
my head's at right now I have seen him
you know just being friends with him and
having conversations and we just did
another podcast with him recently um I
have seen him mature quite a bit like I
think we we do have to remember like
that's a guy in his mid-20s of course
yeah you know actually he wasn't even I
don't know how old he was I remember
laughing at something and I was like
dude he's so much smarter more mature
than I was at 24 23 when it's just
different though again it's it that's
not I don't I didn't have any friends
like him when I was in my early 20s I
think he's he's a very rare individual
and he's 25 now and he's maturing into
he runs a company with uh over 100 plus
employees he's got this like whole
massive operation this massive platform
and he's 25. it's it's uh gonna be
interesting to watch the next five years
if you were to advise him uh what would
you tell him I think he's already
experiencing some of this where he's
looking at his content and injecting
more storytelling into it which I think
is really really smart and something
that Colin and I've been talking to him
about for a long time
um you know it's the same thing I was
saying earlier of I I think it's okay to
to have a deeper connection with
him and and with the with the content
and with the contestants that he has on
there
um
and he can sacrifice some of the you
know hyper retention editing for that
um I also you know a year ago probably
would have told him he potentially is
doing too many things uh and he's
already you know refocused right he's
he's really just focused on the main
Channel and feastables and if you think
about a year ago Beast Burger feastables
uh main Channel reacts gaming right
these are all different things he's
doing right
um plus 25 other right amazing
opportunities yeah people who want to
meet him and this is that right
everything will tug your attention away
and it's he's a he can be excellent in
all of those things but as you as you
grow up as you mature it's like what do
you say yes to what do you say no to and
when you're at that platform where you
have any and every opportunity
um how do you focus right it's it's hard
well the way output is he can be
excellent at any of those but probably
not all of them yeah right yeah not at
the same time right you could do
anything you just can't do everything at
the same time because as a Creator in a
creator-led business you are the
bottleneck for everything and I've spent
time with him he is the bottleneck for
everything right like he needs to be
pulled into the room to to look at
something he has uh you know say on on
all that stuff and he also has the right
you know mind for it he that's the
reason that company's so big and why
he's built such a big platform so where
do you inject that is it across 20
projects or is it across two and
um you know I think they've they've
really refocused and focused on on every
one of these platforms has like a guy at
a certain time or a girl at a certain
time that's like the one they're like
you know you know whether it was like
Casey neistat
I like kind of they have these like epic
arcs and they're the top of the mountain
and then
most of them
either literally stop creating because
they kind of they transition career they
get burnt out whatever it is or they're
still creating but they're just not like
there's the new wave of new people doing
new cool [__]
um
he is kind of remarkable though so you
know he may have a different path or
trajectory than than most if you if I
was to say all right make a prediction
um five years from now
what is like today if Mr Beast is like
you know the number one YouTube Creator
and like launching a couple of these
businesses underneath like feastables
whatnot five years from now do you think
he's still the number one Creator on
YouTube I think he's probably the number
one online digital media company I don't
know that you know I don't know what
Creator is going to mean in that many
years like I think
he has the best pulse on on online
storytelling right now and I think you
know we saw some people try this like
the buzzfeeds the you know like these
these massive media companies that
emerge I think he's more akin to a media
company than he is a Creator
um so I I that's what I think I think
he'll be the biggest media company
um the way he's building is like a true
company it's a great vibe there if
you've been there you know like it's uh
they have good people involved so I
don't know I don't know you know what
the content looks like I don't know what
he as the Creator looks like but I think
it will be a a media company like when
we sat with him last in our last
interview he has a ton of aspirations to
make content for Netflix he has a ton of
aspirations to produce stuff and you
know I don't think he's that Keen or
intent on he has to be in everything or
he has to be the lead in everything
right I think that's been the that is
the draw right now but I think in the
future it Mr Beast is a Content Studio
you know it could be we could be be
looking at like we don't know if we're
not looking at the next Disney or
Paramount or you know some massive
Studio that can build IP and monetize it
in different ways like Mr Beast is the
first if we look at it and say that's
the first show that was built out of
there right it's a game show that has a
couple different formats it's
distributed it's the biggest show right
they built a chocolate brand out of that
that operates kind of like a game show
you can win stuff when you buy the
chocolate right so it's like okay that
looks and feels really similar to like a
Disney and a Mickey Mouse right okay
let's let's build this big media
platform let's build a product connected
to it there they have that skill set
they probably replicate that right and
as you look at their cast of characters
you know there is a cast of characters
there that can be built out
um there is more IP that can be built
out it's like
build IP connect product to it right you
know our connect experiences to it it
could be an experience too yeah if he
chooses to uh to go that path uh I want
to talk about this this is amazing yeah
so your con your content company did
something pretty dope uh
you guys did I think what is 100
editions we had 500 of those no no but
this was to celebrate it was to
celebrate two years of our newsletter
two yeah two years in the newsletter the
published for us yeah so you got this
newsletter the published press uh which
is dope it's like you know what you guys
do on the YouTube channel so like
Creator a great newsletter for creators
I mean it was largely inspired by like
the morning Brew hustle movement right
which was like okay we are subscribers
to these newsletters what if we made one
about our own Community yeah and then uh
then you made actual physical newspaper
yeah I'm very honored because you yeah
pretty much sold out of these yeah
um this was dope why do something like
this because I I I'm asking because this
isn't like an economic move this isn't
this is not gonna grow your audience
it's not going to get you rich yeah it's
not going to do any of those things it
takes effort yeah um it's a risk in a
little in a way
um what's your philosophy on just do
dope [__] like this why
uh it just it's fulfilling like I it's
it's hard to say that we have a
hard-nosed philosophy on it it's just
like we are creative people and as we've
built a business like one of one of the
things that's so interesting about being
a creative is you're really good at kind
of zero to one and the like let's just
do cool [__] until something works
what becomes startling is when something
works and then you're like okay so what
now I just keep doing this doing this
uh and that's like that's the really
funny thing about Colin and I always say
that creatives aren't consistent people
right
um and so we've surrounded ourselves
with really consistent people who help
us be consistent in the formats that we
found
um but you need that occasional pop of
just like you know it'd be cool
to make a newspaper right like we we
were rebranding the publish for us
that's a new logo for it we just we're
like how do we how do we tell people
that we've been doing this for two years
how do we celebrate it also was we had
just crossed a hundred thousand
subscribers on the newsletter and it was
like how do we celebrate this moment
right what is it do we just put out a
tweet that's like hey it's been great
um and we were like well as things are
getting more increasingly more digital
what if we did something physical and
that was it that was the impetus and
then it was just hey is everyone excited
about this okay cool are we down to stay
up late at night for this great and
that's it just organically happens when
you're there's a lot of people who we
asked about this and they were like
that's you know we that's not going to
happen in the time period that we wanted
to happen in and then that's another
exciting thing for a creative person
that's another exciting thing
um so yeah I would say that it it's
again like it cost us money uh we did
not make money from this there's no
sponsor in it or anything
um it it didn't you know dramatically
grow our audience but
um it it has been a moment where a lot
of people could understand what the
brand was and a lot of big creators
reached out to say can I have one yeah
you know I want one in my house and then
we're seeing that creators have framed
it and put it in their house seeing that
there's just something yeah you dm'd us
and asked for one and like that to me is
like again back to this concept of high
quality audience it's like the people
who reached out about this it's a
premium and the real mask is because
it's like in retrospect once you see the
final product in school and then you
hear these stories and it's like yeah
all these things make sense it's
hindsight it's up front when it's kind
of unknown kind of unproven tight
deadline you know a lot of things to do
that's when it's hard to do this or or
sometimes you say yes to too many of
these things right so it's almost like
sure what you just said kind of reminds
me of like Google had like the 20 time
yeah all right hire the best engineers
in the world and like this guy is fixing
the bug in the AdSense platform
but like we got to give these guys like
20 time to just tinker and hack on yeah
stuff that that they you know get
motivation from and like uh logically
you'd say well you're losing you know 20
time is basically one day one day out of
out of the week that they're not working
on on this on their main job but the
reality is that like sometimes those hit
and also it makes the other four days
out of the week yeah more productive
like you don't actually lose anything
totally because you attract the best
people and you gave them an outlet to
like be creative and also if you're not
following what's exciting you then
you're just you built yourself a job
right and that's like then you have to
look at it and be like wait what did I
just do you know what what did I just do
um I also think that you know what we do
with our merchandise and what we do with
anything physical like most of it at the
moment is not driving
crazy Revenue right it's not like a
revenue driver for us but we think about
building our community and we're very
Niche and so for Niche creators we think
about Collectibles like we want to
create Collective right yeah um and when
we have Collectibles then you get to be
a part of our community and be like I'm
it's the feeling of going to see a band
when you were younger and keeping the
ticket stop it's like I was a part of
this community at this moment right so
these are Collectibles along the way of
of our journey you think about the the
massive creators like Logan Paul and Mr
Beast or Emma Chamberlain they're
creating consumables which is great for
Mass creators right so
um these these things are like cool
Collectibles that we think are cool like
we're planning another drop in in
October and our merchandise does not
you know uh drive like crazy amounts of
revenue for us it's relatively nominal
but it's awesome when you walk down the
street and see someone in the merch
which sold you know 2 000 of these hats
and they're they're out in the world and
right 2 000 people are wearing them and
we've we see stories where people
connect because they saw someone else
wearing the merge so that to me is like
the symbol of community building this
tight-knit group uh who can connect and
be like I'm part of the same group as
you identify in the same world as you do
totally we uh
that I love the way you put it it's a
great frame on that idea of consumables
versus Collectibles when we uh we're
about to launch like merch for the Pod
or whatever and it was like oh yeah
merch and it's like okay here's two
things I know number one people don't
want to wear or like for us it was like
they're not gonna wear a shirt that says
my first million like this is not gonna
happen it's not cool I don't want to
wear that bait I want to wear that let's
just all agree on that what they will
wear is like
inside jokes and slang that only you if
you know you know and if you don't you
don't no small stuff yeah no small boy
stuff or like I have this shirt that
it's a we made that's a Polaroid of it's
like a fuzzy Polaroid of Sam when he had
his hot dog stand it's like in the style
of those like Kanye shirt or whatever
it's like some like cool cool looking
like it's like an imitation of that
right and it's like nobody will even
know who that is or what you can't even
tell that it's a hot dog stand but like
if you know you know and that's and
that's it and I was like we should just
do I was like in front my rule is like
the Tim Ferriss rule is basically if
you're not gonna make a ton of money on
it it should be free or it should be
like as just sell it at Cost but like
and do like a limited run so that it's
more interesting totally and just only
like if you're gonna try to make money
only make money when you're gonna make a
lot of money don't try to like trickle a
little bit of beg for money everywhere
because that doesn't like
nobody likes that and that's not the
right approach for someone like this and
a lot of our Merchants also the right
way to think about it a lot of our merch
shipments are driven by a referral
program through the newsletter right
right so that's like you know again
that's like pulling from the The
Playbook yeah the the whole the
newsletter Playbook you had this um
tweet or this video that I saw that was
like a naval quote that I really liked
it was um it said like uh was it was
like your problem is that you're writing
to be read yes
that resonated with you and me I want to
like talk about that why did that hit
because so simple it's like you know
yeah seven words or something I think it
hit me at a time where I felt like we
were creating very scared the beginning
of this year I felt like we were
creating very scared like we had crossed
a million subscribers last year we felt
like we had built a brand in the space
and opened up the year we made a few
videos that we just canned we just
didn't put them out because we were like
oh those aren't going to work for the
audience but we liked them
um and got really in our heads around
you know again you're playing this dance
as a creator of what you want to make
what the audience wants to watch and
what the platform wants right those are
the three things that we think you're
you're constantly playing with and if
you overvalue what the audience wants
you will you're you're catering to you
know this group that obviously they have
created your career if you know you've
made it um but you you can't forget that
it came from what you wanted to make I
think on on one side of the spectrum of
you know being a publisher or being a
Creator there is the artist who's like I
do not care what you think I'm going to
make this and that has financial
implications right that are essentially
very hard to make money like that but
very cool we respect artists like that
right
um there's some most respected artists
like are misunderstood maybe understood
once they pass or just didn't care about
what the audience thought right uh your
interpretation doesn't matter to them
right then you go on like love that you
exist but like sure I like guac on my
Chipotle I'm gonna have a job it's okay
the other side of the spectrum is being
a distributor it's like why do we have
so many Spider-Man movies because they
put butts in seats right so the person
at the studio the movie studio is not an
artist they're thinking about what do we
make what are we green light Spider-Man
that's going to get people in the seats
that's going to sell tickets and I think
as a Creator you have to be in the
middle of that and some creators slide
heavy on the the side of distributor of
just like what does the audience want to
watch I'll make that whatever you know
and then on the other side of what do I
want to make
um and so I think that Naval quote
really hit me in this feeling of losing
you know I did grow up I went to film
school I you know took playwriting in
college I'm like really into artsy stuff
and I think when money gets involved
when you start commercializing your
creativity
um and when it doesn't work for years
that's an important part of our story
right it didn't work for a long time we
didn't make any money for a long time
you get terrified of losing it and when
you get terrified of losing it you start
creating to be watched or writing to be
read would you say creating scared yeah
creating scared yeah let's take a book
title right there I like that one yeah
it's something Colin and I talk about a
lot it's like let's not create scared
you know what are we scared of you know
like again it's it's all this mix of the
public view count the perception the
tweets of like these guys have fallen
off or whatever you think is going to
happen if you put out a video that
people don't like
um and people can feel that I think I
think you can feel it as a Creator it
feels really uncomfortable to to create
scared and right
um yeah it's not it's not fun to watch
yeah absolutely you know um you had
Husson
he's very much on the artist side I
think uh he like drew a line in the sand
for himself he's like Okay I uh
either I'm gonna get on Tick Tock and
I'm gonna dance for the algorithm yeah
or I'm going to go the other way and I'm
not and he's like had like the soul
searching moment it's not like you know
he he sent me a voice memo once I was
just like bro I'm gonna just create
great art I'm an artist and an artist
creates art that's what I'm doing I'm
not a businessman first I'm not a
Creator first I'm this is what I'm gonna
do and he's like so I gotta be true to
that and I'm gonna work on projects that
are like interesting to me from that
perspective and it's got to hit my bar
on that and like that's the vibe I got
from him but you know this was a few
years ago when I yeah when we were
talking about that stuff you had them on
I think more recently yeah um end of
last year did he say anything that kind
of resonated with you on that totally
yeah I mean he talked a lot about he
kind of changed my whole perception on
making YouTube shorts I guess he what
did he say he kind of made he kind of
made fun of it uh you know husband's
like so funny the way he he talks but he
he described making YouTube shorts as
being a skinned rat for the engineers in
San Bruno which I thought was really
funny uh he was just like you're a
guinea pig you are
um you know essentially creating more
data points for them for their you know
you're you're they're your boss um you
know whatever works on their algorithm
you then Pander to that right and so he
he kind of pushed Us in that that
direction of recognizing like are we
artists or are we creating for the
algorithm
um and the second thing he said which I
I heavily resonate with he's like
everything is about the PDF which means
like what is the idea right write it on
a piece of paper is the idea good show
it to someone pitch it to someone do
they immediately go that's a good idea
do they laugh do they feel some sort of
emotion before it's before it's made
yeah yeah and he's like people even when
we got on our pre-call with him he was
like all right what are we making
together when we sit down right and he
asked us that question and I was like oh
you're right what is the Hassan Minaj
calling and Samir interview let's write
it out let's let's not plan it but what
is it like what's the idea why is this a
good idea to do this right uh what was
the answer
we talked about like how can we
um like how can we bring forward his
creator story of starting on YouTube and
using YouTube to um go through kind of
this crazy windy path up to Netflix
right and how he's now kind of left
YouTube
um
you used to upload he came up with shows
and and put them on YouTube if you go to
his channel and search by oldest like I
like sketch shows sketch shows he did
hosted shows where he talked about the
news like almost like Tosh uh
yeah that for us was like no one's no
one has told that story that's
interesting let's talk about that and
let's talk about your relationship with
with and he was almost like 18 19 doing
like comedy clubs right like he's doing
stand-up and like yeah San Francisco or
something like that totally yeah I
watched him uh do King's Jester live uh
like we went out to go did you go to one
of his shows that was really good so
that's a stand-up special
um
that guy's like a performer man like he
he re he really inspired me to be like
this isn't like a comedy show yeah it's
a one-man show it's a performance uh and
that to me it really inspired both Colin
and I to be like this is a craft you
have to work on it you know performing
is part of this Craft
um ideation is the biggest part of it
you know he has a writing partner that
he sits did you meet Fred or yeah what's
he like I've never gotten to meet him um
but I'm very I'm very very fascinated by
kind of the the wingman yeah like
there's a library there's a lot of
popular popular people
but almost all of them are not nobody's
solo everyone's got some kind of a team
and usually they have like their their
Confidant the person who's in the bunker
with them figuring things out
compliments them does all the [__]
they're not good at
um but like kind of like keeps them
going in the right direction and those
people are actually really really
fascinating to me and nobody really like
ask them a ton of questions I have a
million questions for them uh what tell
me a little bit about him I think
oftentimes as as creatives and creators
we think we're we want to hire an
employee but actually what we want is a
collaborator yeah and if you're lucky
enough to come up with a collaborator
then you know those are the people in my
opinion who typically make it like fully
make it when they have a collaborator so
Pratt a limited time with him but um I
find comedians to be like astute
observers of the world and uh I found
Pratt to be like very much that right
like he he had a notebook and Pen during
the king's gesture taping it was a I
don't know if it was a taping or if it
was just one of the shows but they were
prepping for the Netflix special yeah
and he was sitting there during the
entire show he was sitting right in
front of me just ferociously taking
notes on what was working what the
audience was reacting to when there was
too too much of a pause when there
wasn't like he was um and right after
the show before Hudson came back into
the Green Room him and Pratt were
talking I love that yeah I love it when
it's sort of like all right we're going
back to the lab lab yeah it's like we
kind of like we do our thing but like
because I tell so Ben's my collaborator
basically so like we did a couple
businesses together but also when it
comes to content like we recently did
um we're kind of new to YouTube but we
did we used to just basically put the
podcast on YouTube yeah I remember and
that was like you guys are growing now
though I started really bad it was like
we were the first time we didn't
remember we had like 4 000 views and I
was just like oh man like but like which
is fine for when you start but we
already had the podcast was significant
so it's like it's kind of like if you
play poker at one stakes and then you go
down to the micro Stakes like you know
quarters in the 10 cent table doesn't
feel very fun because you've now
experienced a different uh level of
stakes but those aren't even in the same
Casino yeah Spotify or apple pods on
YouTube yeah it's a completely different
group of people so exactly so so we were
like all right we think we could do this
and so we started grow but recently we
did one and it's this uh it says money
one that's on the right there that has
how many views I have now
nice so 300 000 views and this was a
video it was the first video that I made
YouTube first I was like okay I'm gonna
uh create a video that I think is gonna
be like YouTube it's not just a podcast
and me and Ben were like what if we just
took three days it's like we just tried
to make one great video for this and we
did and we made that and we were
basically collaborating on that for the
first time we had done that that way
but the cool thing is now we've been
working together for a couple years and
you get this like mine meld where it's
like yeah it's almost like uh you only
could you could speak in shorthand or
reference like it's like if you say
something I already know what part he's
gonna be like oh we gotta talk about
that later right because that relates to
these other three things and then
earlier we talked about this but that's
and it's like if you can get to that
point that's like a pretty like
formidable thing that I think most
people don't have but when you have it
it's like oh [__] this is that lets you
go places I think you need someone who's
excited and wants to to be a part of a
team where their name isn't at the
Forefront right which which can be
really complex right but we know who
Pratt is but if you're a fan of Hassan
scale you're not going to know who he is
uh so you have to find someone who's
really into that too right who likes
especially every person if you've ever
tried to hire a lot of people like I
want to work for you because I want to
be you because I want to be you yeah and
it's like okay cool but that doesn't
really work like especially with this
group that's what I need yeah yeah this
group right now it's hard to hire
someone who doesn't want to be the
Creator or you know is is trying to be
become a Creator and working with you to
be like okay now I get it now I'm gonna
go right do it um but yeah you have to
find someone who's Who's down for that
but it's it is kind of like being an
athlete where you know you guys when I
leave you're gonna talk about the
performance right you're gonna you're
gonna probably watch game tape back
you're gonna watch it back and be like
oh maybe I should have asked this
question there or maybe this would have
been more interesting or he went a
little long here I should have stopped
him you know like there's so much uh
that goes into this that if you deeply
care about the craft and you have
someone who cares that much about the
craft you can get better at the craft be
a better faster give me a better way
faster yeah it's hard to find right it
typically happens just organically and
then you're like okay this is my guy now
right how much do you guys so you guys
have your business off the back of your
thing which is the news the newsletter's
a yeah kind of a different type of
business it's actually a separate
company and there's separate people
writing that thing it's not you guys
creating it necessarily have you seen
and uh I'm I'm keeping track of these
kind of Creator driven businesses where
you have like almost like a an audience
co-founder and like the way you used to
have like a technical co-founder for a
business now you have one like a
distribution co-founder or an audience
that's cool what have you seen that
maybe everybody hasn't heard of right
because I think everybody's kind of
heard of Mr Beast and maybe a couple
others but
um what are some cool ones that you're
keeping an eye on or I should know about
or other people should know about the
typical Creator business is make content
sell ads right which is like that's
that's Baseline some people never need
to grow out of that because that's just
a good business
um but like when when you go through
those extensions like I think Ali abdall
has a fantastic education business uh
he's a Creator out of the UK who talks
about productivity and um he's built a
series of courses and wasn't he a doctor
too he was a doctor prior yeah you're
right he's a doctor he's an excellent
teacher but he has built a great
business
um that is you know very much focused on
online education I think he publishes
his number he publishes his number is
like four million a year on his like
four or five million on his pushing to
six this year Creator Academy yeah which
is like basically become a YouTuber yes
yeah s and he has a ton of courses on
skillshare about like studying for the
MCAT or like he's just figured out that
okay I'm really good at making online
video yes one of those ways is to
monetize through advertising but another
one is through pages your online videos
and that's the classic like build one
sell twice right it's like you build it
it lives on skillshare or on your own
website for years to come people can buy
it right so I I really like the digital
product business
um because it's just scalable and we do
very few things that are scalable as
creators right
um I also think there's a um there's a
future model now which is potentially
there's a a Creator named Amelia de
moldenberg who has a show called chicken
chop date
um it's a great show are you the one who
showed me yeah it's a great show she
she's had Jack Harlow on it she just had
Jennifer Lawrence on it said what's this
what's the stick it's like out of
chicken shop like it's a date yeah it's
a date at a fried chicken place in
London and the chicken shop in London is
like the last place you would go right
to have a date so there's comedy in it
she's a comedian
um and through yeah through this so
she's had like this has now spun her
into essentially creating her own
production company where Brands come to
her and say we love your shtick we love
your comedy we love the way you've
created this show
um like this show has no advertising in
it no advertisers and will never have
advertisers and this thing does you know
the Jack Harlow episode has 15 million
views
um this regularly does you know one to
five million views in the first week but
no advertisers and what it operates as
is like it's a production company and
Nike just came to her so she kind of
created an agency she created an agency
yeah so like Nike came to her approved
like I can create cool likable content
it's vertically integrated where she can
come up with the idea then her company
can shoot the idea then she can be the
talent in the idea and then the thing
that I think we forget is like she's the
distribution outlet for that idea too
where did she post on her own on her own
YouTube channel yeah so she she doesn't
do ads but she'll put like full episodes
she went and hosted the Barbie Premiere
um that's smart so I like that there's
another
um Creator named Amanda rashley who's
who's uh based in Canada and what she
did is she started YouTube
by showing bullet journaling and how she
was setting up her bullet journals and
what is it so go to the channel Amanda
r-a-c-h and then Lee uh and now yeah
like go to like one of these bullet
Journal setups this just looks like Etsy
of YouTube yeah yeah and how many views
does it have
three million so when she started she
was doing these bullet Journal setups
like here's how I set up my journal
and then what she did was swap out the
journal she was using and create her own
custom Journal company and that to me is
like epitome of Creator business right
where it's what Colin and I call content
product fit she didn't have to change
the content right to integrate the
product yeah right you just I mean to
talk about a big example it's
Chamberlain coffee when Emma Chamberlain
launched that she drank coffee in every
episode right swap her coffee product
placement but yeah done at like a whole
nother level yeah yeah and I think you
know it's something we're actually
struggling with with our uh newsletter
um which is like our version of that how
do we integrate that in every episode
sure we can bring it up but that doesn't
drive subscribers right um so it's it's
Logan Paul said this about prime he said
a lot of creators when they talk about
their own product it sounds like they're
doing a brand deal yeah they don't know
how to integrate it regularly you know
and like the milk boys with happy Dad
right their alcohol is in every single
episode right because there's still no
presenters yeah yeah
um Logan has Prime everywhere with him
um so you know I think creators who have
this like Amanda they can build really
substantial business content product fit
yeah content product fit
um so this is a really impressive
business to me because it's just it's
niche but three million people watch
this and she sells this journal yeah
that's insane yeah she's got to be doing
I mean
what do you think she's making on
something like this I I've spent time
with her she's never told me but I will
say that she speaks at a lot of Shopify
events that's like a a very good case
study for them uh I know she's doing
well she has a good team
um the thing I love about this business
too it's it's repeat purchases there's a
new Journal drop you can run out of
pages in a journal once you know once
you have allegiance to this it's like
yeah you know great uh so I I've had
this idea for because I'm a big Journal
guy yeah and so uh I was like oh dude I
want to create my own because I don't
know I like I have an idea of what I
want mine to be I just haven't made it
so if I'm gonna make it for myself maybe
I'll make your brothers but the best uh
example my favorite example of this is
actually a really small Stakes one which
is the Ryan holiday coin totally that's
like such a good example of this because
he was like he's the way he described it
so first it was like the content uh
product fit where he's just like
stoicism here's the like reminder coin
that like you're gonna die you know
whatever you remember you're gonna die
whatever but he was like you know I've
done like t-shirts t-shirts suck yeah
and he's like I wanted something that
was like I could fit in an envelope a
normal envelope so like mailing was easy
I wanted something I can manufacture
here so I don't have to like produce
overseas whatever he's like no sizes no
colors it's like just like they're so
good yeah like there's one skew and I'm
gonna sell and I think he sold like 20
million dollars of this one snow over
there really yeah I'm pretty sure I
think I'm pretty sure he's out on our
episode or we like
I think probably one of the biggest
creator-led companies
um right now that that maybe isn't as as
prominent in the mainstream conversation
is Mark rober's crunch Labs which is
like a subscription subscription box
stem or something right like he's like
yeah exactly it's a science kit I got it
for my nephews it is excellent they are
hooked on it nice like it is excellent I
text Mark about I'm like dude this
product is crazy like it's huge that's
your big business huge yeah that's a big
business
um yeah yeah and I know he said now that
that makes more than his channel yeah I
mean his channel is massive that's
that's another rating because he does
basically crazy science experiments
right a threat yeah and he has big
versions of that in his videos so like
he'll make a big version of it right and
then he'll be like and you can make a
miniature version of this at home I
think this content model this what
you're just describing here these
examples is um like I always think about
when I meet someone I'm like wow you had
so much success like what'd you do and
they're often the story is basically
like
you know there was like a moment in time
where like if you realized like X like X
thing works which is like in the early
days of Google it would be like I could
buy clicks for a cent for like any
keyword like that's insane like okay let
me just work backwards what's the best
keyword and like so that's how I got
into like selling leads to lawyers or
whatever like you know asbestos you know
removal company or whatever and then
it's like um like our buddy created
native deodorant and he's like yeah
basically like
I started this when Facebook ads were
kind of like underused and people were
only using them for like like media
companies were trying to buy Facebook
ads but then they were like driving them
back to a blog post and monetizing with
a Google ad there right right it's not
really a good model yeah I realized like
you can sell just like a product through
Facebook ads with really simple ads and
you don't want like things that you used
to have to go into Target get Target to
carry you you could just start selling
directly to Consumer through Facebook
d2c I mean like there wasn't really like
as much of a category yet but it's like
if you knew if you knew that secret
during that time it was kind of an Open
Secret but not like it wasn't obvious to
everybody yet yeah I mean I think
movement watch is another great
influencers online marketing but I think
what's incredibly hard especially for
creators right now is what you have to
sacrifice to have that that view and
that long-term view of building a
product because
um advertising revenue is so available
right now to us and again you you kind
of pull the levers when it comes to
YouTube It's the highest margin
advertising dollars that I think you
know has did in video content ever right
because
you don't get on the phone with the
advertiser you aren't you aren't
negotiating a contract there's no sales
team there's no back and forth there's
no revision yeah but YouTube takes what
like 45 yeah but still it's like you
know dude you just don't see it you
don't see it it's just like and like you
don't do any work you don't have to do
any work you don't do it right you just
you upload content you get a check in
the mail
um so creators who make really viral
content that has reasonably high cpms
it's like I should you know I should
make another video and then a brand deal
comes and that can be you know anywhere
from from twenty fifty thousand dollars
all the way up to 200 000 right you're
like well okay all right I'll make
another one of those videos and then
what I find is that a lot of creators
never get to that moment of okay now we
should stop and put our focus in right
over here and how do we even do that
it's a totally different skill set yeah
how do I even do that how do I hire
someone I think that's the biggest need
in the Creator economy right now is
operators are the biggest need yes and
education on how to hire is so it's just
not there right because they were it's
all young people who who is funny by the
way because there's so many operators
because I'm coming to an operator yeah
yeah and all the operators like dude I
could if I just had the right influence
or this is a soap we could sell a lot of
this soap right or whatever the thing is
you know pick your favorite widget and
uh and for them it's like a total black
box like how do I go meet these people
get them to trust me enough to do this
and so it's like this this and then also
have the temperament to to want that
right like a lot of creators have to
they might conceptually think they want
it but then when they get into it and
their name is on a soap product right
and they don't really like that it went
out to a customer and it wasn't perfect
and then they're like oh I don't want to
do this every Friday they freak out they
freak out right because it's like I have
so much control over how my brand shows
up
um that when you start to scale that it
gets uncomfortable right so and do you
um I have this question up here I put on
this list three creators likely to
become a billionaire I give you the one
for EB you can say Jimmy and uh he could
be one yeah
what other creators do you think have
the potential to build a billion dollar
Empire around what they're doing it's a
combination of their content plus
businesses whatever I think Dude Perfect
um I saw they did like a amusement park
or something like well they're working
on it yeah yeah 100 million dollar
project yes yes what does that mean
that's what they're investing into this
project I don't know the specifics of it
I've spent a lot they're actually I've
known them for a really long time like I
you know I've been on YouTube and around
YouTube for 12 years they were the first
group that I got involved with um early
on when when we sold our last company
um and they're kind of like the trick
shots will do it yeah they worked but
they make Sports accessible to you know
young kids through trick shots and and
um you know viral sports videos and the
the reason I bring it up is like I think
those guys have been at this now since
around 2006 or seven right and they have
remained
at the top of their game throughout that
whole experience they also went through
a long period of time where you know
they've done the work like I watched
them hold the cameras for years even
when they were at 30 million subscribers
they would just go out themselves right
hold the cameras and edit the videos and
they still sit there in in the edit bays
and make sure they're perfect and
um I think they if you if you've seen
images of they just did a tour see
images of like the fans young kids who
turn out for that the parents
um I had a conversation with them one
time where they said their goal is to be
the the most trusted brand in
entertainment and I actually believe
that they are they're on track for that
where parents really trust that they can
take their kids to a Dude Perfect event
right and that when you take that to an
amusement park when you take that a
couple steps forward I think that
matters a lot in the future
um and I think they're they're on track
for sure that makes sense that makes
sense I like that pick uh anyone else
come to mind that you think has the
potential to to do something large like
that I think uh I I think of some
creators who have the potential but I
don't know if they want to do it you
know like I I think Cody Coe is actually
someone who's uh he's coming here
tomorrow oh he is yeah I love Cody I
know you went on his show yeah I think
Cody is like one of the most intelligent
people I've met uh in the space
I think he he even as he's like in
starting to invest now and I can just I
was thinking about it because him and I
were texting yesterday and I was
thinking in my head I was like who's
Cody Co in 10 years he's either like in
the woods you know like yeah
man DJing and running or he's like
running the biggest Capital company you
know like and I think that's just a
personal choice up to him it's all
available to him
um but yeah I I don't know that uh I'm
sure there's others that I'm not
thinking of but they're my favorite
brand on YouTube TMG TMG is my I agree
on your favorite Channel on YouTube I
think Noel Miller's like a true artist
special and special like I think there's
very rare people like him and also very
not very many people like Cody Co right
um so yeah music videos are so goddamn
good it's actually kind of it's kind of
frustrating yeah it's like a bit it's a
bit off-putting like dude what like you
can't just do that right at that you can
do it as a joke it can't also be amazing
it'll be good yeah it can't also be good
it can't also make me want to listen to
it multiple times right yeah funny and
amazing Annie you just did it like for
kicks on the side right on top of your
other successful thing I find this like
Pursuit of being a billionaire to be
very fascinating like I I I don't really
have interest in it if it if it's the
outcome of what I decide to do that
would be interesting but it's not like I
don't find myself to be
um focused on that outcome and I also
found most creators I talk to are not
focused on that outcome totally
um but I think it's in the video game of
Entrepreneurship it is the final boss
right so you're kind of like if your
final boss is actually walking away sure
yeah the person who says they have
enough is is like like uh you know Paul
Graham who created YC which is I think
probably the most successful Tech
startup actually because it created sure
all these other Tech startups and like I
created Dropbox and it created Airbnb
like they probably wouldn't like to say
created but like they without them there
is no Reddit there is no there are there
probably aren't those those businesses
being successful including open AI
because right he saw Sam Altman and made
him president
when there was tons of other more
qualified candidates on paper but he's
like this even says something he's like
this is like what it would be like to
talk to a young Bill Gates like saw that
before and now he's created open AI
which is yeah today the most you know
one of the most valuable private
startups so anyways YC uh gets to the
peak of its powers or gets like you know
does amazing amazing stuff 10 years in
and Paul's like Sam here you go I'm
going to the woods in the UK and I'm
gonna live in the woods with my family
and I'm gonna basically like write
essays paint and code and like you know
that's what I'm gonna do
and that is the final boss of Silicon
Valley because you see most people just
go right back into the hamster wheel and
they start running again but that's like
the final boss of life right it's like
making that realization is not wanting
anymore yeah yeah being like content and
and developing a relationship with the
term enough yeah that's that's a hard
thing to do but totally do you have that
do you have a number or like a do you
feel like you have enough like what are
you in pursuit of
um I'm in pursuit of a really specific
thing which is
um I Heard a quote once that I think
Naval said he goes
uh the the day you stop trading today
for a better tomorrow you've retired so
he's like um basically if the things you
do today in and of themselves were the
reward of what you did today
you've now you've actually exited the
game you've retired retirement doesn't
mean you go sit down and do nothing it
means you're not saying all right I'm
gonna do this [__] today that I don't
really want to do I don't like to do but
I'm doing it because it's gonna pay off
in the future it's gonna pay off in the
future like
your whole life goes by doing that yeah
and so
when I heard that I was like oh you know
guilty like you know put me in put me in
cuffs take me to jail like totally
that's me I'm I've spent the first you
know 15 years of my career like you know
from 20 to 35 basically was that I was
like oh I'm gonna do X and I'm gonna say
I didn't enjoy it necessarily but like
definitely I was like doing X because it
might lead to why I totally agree I've
never just done access that too yeah
I've never just made my main thing like
I'm doing X because I'm just doing X
seems fun yeah and so that's the that's
the game I'm playing now
is to try to achieve that
um to craft my life such that that's
true and so um even though it's like
weird it's like you know it's awesome
it's like what I like to do best I don't
know I like to I like to do this podcast
I like to read I like to talk and I like
to like yeah uh you know work on these
little Tinker with these little things
or you know just understand go down
rabbit holes and just see how things
work in the world and it's like those
are the things that I do without
thinking about some like future payoff
because I don't think they even like or
they don't clearly have one well you can
also have the there's another Tim
Ferriss uh moment in our in our episode
together he was like something to the
tune of like you can decouple the
um the non-financial reward and the
financial reward right right so like
this experience
um there's a non-financial reward to
this which is like we have a good
conversation right cool this is fun we
both go home that reward is complete
then you put it out if there's a
performance reward to it amazing if that
leads to financial opportunity great you
know like but that's a separate reward
and if you can decouple those things
then that is uh yeah and just basically
uh like the way I think about stuff is
like there's a car and uh you can have a
bunch of passengers in the car it's like
you know I have like my ego but
hopefully it's in the trunk it shouldn't
be driving like you know let's put them
in the back you know yeah yeah he's kind
of annoying but he's there and you got
like you know the thrill of things
that's in the car but I don't really
want thrill to drive because he takes us
off the cliff like who gets to drive and
so uh you know that's kind of like so to
me I'm like all right who gets to drive
is like the version of me that is uh
following my curiosity creating [__]
consistent like just creating things
yeah and is content with life and has
like a
I'm doing it because I want to do it I'm
doing it because it's enjoyable to do
I'm doing it because it's challenging so
even if it's not that enjoyable like I'm
struggling at it I'm enjoying the
struggle of doing this thing yeah and so
that's who I want to drive meaning
that's who gets to ultimately make the
decision of where are we going in this
car other people might have input other
the other parts of me might have input
like I want money I want this I want
that yeah but I can't like like
basically money was driving for a long
ass time and then it's like hold on wait
the deal was you get to drive till we
get to this number we got to that number
you don't get to drive anymore yeah and
maybe you shouldn't have been driving
for the first place but at least in my
life I was like I want to get to
basically a Financial Freedom number a
number where
I can spend whatever I want in my
lifestyle and it's coming off of my
investment income not out of like my
work income yeah uh because then it's
like all right cool money works for
money I work for me man I think that is
a big opportunity with uh creators it'd
be like a smaller group but I think as
creators we're really good at generating
money but we don't know how to turn
money into money right because we're
it's like it's a totally different it's
a totally different skill set and then
we don't know who to trust with that you
know I think if there was a Creator
focused group that helped with that that
well we went to this athlete thing
yesterday with a bunch of there's a
bunch of basketball players there and
it's the same thing like literally we
were joking we were like this event
would be cool if it was just the
athletes who do what they do and us but
then you have all the clingers yeah and
you're like who do I trust and then like
yeah and like and some of the clingers
are the people they trust and they're
like kind of safe choices they don't
actually know how to do the thing for
them sure it's like you know actually if
they asked I would for free help them or
tell them exactly what they should be
doing so that their money works for
money and they don't they piss it away
yeah but um the incentive is not for me
to go chase them and reach them and then
beg them to listen to my advice yeah the
guy who's trying to take their money is
incentivized sure to chase them and beg
them and and try to convince them that
they're the guy who's gonna help them
right it's like this weird like perverse
incentive it's like the guy who's gonna
like work his hardest to break into your
circle
is the one who wants something yeah you
actually don't want to work with someone
who's like needs something to you yeah
yeah on the sports topic there's one
more um destroying uh he is a sports
Creator a football focused career he he
played football at uh UCF and this is
pre-nil days right so he played football
he was making YouTube videos they
brought him into a room and said you
have a choice you can either continue
playing football or you can continue
with your YouTube channel he chose
YouTube
um and built this this really
substantial YouTube channel he has this
series called one-on-ones uh that just
go live to places like he goes to like
the city yeah this is like Live Events
and they get crazy like in Arizona it
had to get called off because it was
like too many people there and the
police had to get involved uh I was
gonna go he but I think he he messaged
or his management somebody messaged okay
okay I mean yeah like he's an hour away
I was like oh that sounds kind of fun
but it's like I didn't make it out what
does he do so it's one on one so
basically it's wide receivers versus
cornerbacks and that line up and they go
a one-on-one and one dude wins ten
thousand dollars and for some of the
communities he's going into that's
life-changing right right for a lot of
communities he's the guy in the thing or
it's he's the two other guys I think
he's the host
um you know and like here you can see
like this is this is what it looks like
um
if you go to his channel and go to most
viewed
so cool so that so that guy if that guy
had caught it he would have he would
have ten grants it's a tournament and
you and then you start to know these
characters and they travel to different
markets this is the new and one mixtape
exactly this is Android mixtape for
football and um Colin and I spoke with
uh at a YouTube event with Dee and he
was speaking with Roger Goodell and we
were talking to Roger about destroying
and he was like this guy's like really
impactful for football oh wow he's
creating new fans and the NFL just
partnered with him on this series The
one-on-one series and I think when I
look at D like the leagues are starting
to get involved with him in a way where
I'm like wait he is single-handedly
a really uh important part of the future
of sports viewership yeah and that to me
I don't know that he I don't know if he
has aspirations to be a billionaire but
to solve that problem for the NFL is a
uh big problem to solve and if you solve
that for the CFL and you start solving
that you know you go down the line this
can also become camps totally can become
you know so many things right the world
is his oyster he can become a host he
he's probably should be one of the hosts
uh for the NFL like or like the Pro Bowl
which no one's watching I think he can
also create a uh yeah I mean he can
redefine the Pro Bowl because this is
more interesting way more yeah I'm like
half looking at you because you're
watching this I mean we pulled this up
in our office and we have a ton of
people who don't watch sports and then
they got hooked on it they were like
this is Primal it's a primal yeah and so
he could redefine the pro ball he can
also create a nil agency right so you
have college athletes who he represents
this you know where College athletics
didn't let you monetize he knows how to
do this right so okay now can D create a
nil agency where he's signing athletes
and getting them contracts he the world
of D like the World of Sports no one is
really approaching it like him and I
think that like sports is still highs or
carries a very high dollar value live
sports yeah um it carries such high uh
dollar value that I think he has that
opportunity as well there was a guy at
that event we were at that was um you'll
know him because he's lacrosse Paul Ray
ball yeah yeah he's a groomsmen in my
wedding he's one of my best friends
amazing he is I don't know much about
this boardroom event yeah yeah so tell
me about it so basically he what he was
saying on stage was like okay we created
this professional lacrosse league yeah
what was interesting he was like there's
like whatever I don't know eight teams
or something but he's like We Own the
teams yeah it's not like a franchise
model and I think he's like we pay the
costs but then like all the players have
upside and the thing like what is the
business model of this this sounded
pretty fascinating and yeah so I think
it's a good model also I'm an investor
so a biased opinion yes but I've uh you
know what I've always seen in in
Lacrosse if you pull up um go to the
premier Lacrosse League YouTube channel
and and play the last Vlog from their
All-Star Game you get a sense for like
the community that one the fastest shot
uh right that yeah so you get a sense
for like what it looks like I mean
they're they were going wild but like
they they packed the stadium out in
Louisville for their All-Star game so
basically what he did was there was a
pre-existing League called Major League
lacrosse they paid their players
terribly uh they treated them no that
was the best league that was the only
pro league it was like and no one really
cared about it I mean like it was It was
kind of interesting but it was empty
stadiums they didn't have health care it
was like they weren't treated like it
was tough to be a pro athlete and not
get paid much right and Paul became the
you know number one uh lacrosse play
area the biggest media platform Colin
and I actually ran his YouTube channel
that's how we became very close
um we were running a lot of different
athlete YouTube channels at one point
and so we became really close to Paul
that's how we met
um and he had the best head on his
shoulder for like media how do you build
a brand how do you you know he had the
biggest he was called lacrosse's first
million dollar man he had deals with Red
Bull and New Balance and
um he had created the model for like how
do you make money and was he was he the
best and he was the best at Media or he
was actually the best at media and
really good no he's he's the he was the
best he was the best player he's the
best player yeah yeah so those are those
like Conor McGregor at one time he's the
champ yeah and yeah he's like the most
marketable guy so he he decided uh you
know at one point just to say hey you
know what we're gonna go raise money and
create our own League like this league
sucks that I plan
um that's what he did he turned to Joe
Tai who's uh the Nets owner yeah Nets
owner uh who played lacrosse in college
and loves lacrosse right and he's a
great dude met him a couple times and uh
he became the lead investor and then
they partnered with with rain group and
um they raised a bunch of money and said
we're going to pay the players a
reasonable salary or give them equity in
the league we're gonna give them Health
Care uh and we are going to create media
around them we're going to create media
opportunities for them we're going to
teach them how to you know and the last
thing they did was they said we're not
going to stick these teams in local
markets we're going to actually take the
whole league on tour makes sense so they
they develop that makes more sense it's
like a touring you know circus where
it's like is it coming to San Diego this
weekend okay everyone descends about
this major major Market yeah
you know if you have lacrosse people
they come to town twice a year exactly
we'll go to that we may not go all the
time or there may not be enough people
to support a stadium well I think also
what he knew and what what we saw was
that the model in Lacrosse well you made
money was by doing camps and Clinics
right so you you you have youth camps
right like there's a lot of young kids
who want to play they come from affluent
backgrounds their parents are willing to
pay a thousand dollars for them to get
coached by their favorite lacrosse
player
um and Paul built a massive camps
business and so alongside this you go to
a major market now you have a weekend
dedicated to you can have camps you can
turn all these players into okay Camp
counselors and and trainers earn extra
money or whatever they can build their
own bespoke businesses but that all you
know connect to the league and that's
um so he him and his brother are really
sharp and they didn't sell franchises
yet not yet yeah and they uh bar stools
involved in one of them okay uh they
they got to name the expansion team and
uh pardon my take like they're the
owners uh the water dogs that's like the
ridiculous name yeah but like that you
know there's that creates a kind of that
that inside joke with the part of PMT
community that it's like they have their
own team it's like collab
because when they play Big Cats tweeting
about about it uh when they they won the
championship last year he got his own
ring you know it's like amazing they're
able to build again they're very media
Savvy and so they they understand that
this is a long game lacrosse is not well
to build any League I think it texted
you this during the event I was like I
think what this guy's saying is actually
quite smart we should look at investing
and I go I'll go man building a league
is hard like fun if you do it easy that
is like one of the hardest games you
could play in the world of
Entrepreneurship is creating a sports
League from scratch because it's like
kind of a 20-year Arc to actually get
that you have to have such a long view
on the world and on your life to do it
and you're doing Live Events you're
doing all the hardest things I mean
every weekend he's in a different city
you know I'm watching these and and
looking the most promising thing is look
how young the kids are who are there
right right so if they grow up with this
league these teams these franchises like
they are playing a very long game here
um and I credit them to for doing it but
it's uh it's not an easy thing they sign
like a 10 million dollar deal or
something with ESPN like ESPN yeah
yeah so when they first started Colin
and I made a documentary about them for
NBC uh that's right we've had like many
different lives of you know Colin and
Samir but yeah that's amazing do you
think that's going to be uh you know
good investment for you where you like
the first one in because he's like your
buddy I was first one in uh which was
great so it's doing good yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's doing that right now like
um
like you're gonna get like you're gonna
let's say this works out hopefully like
you know like we we all we're rooting
for this
like you're gonna make a bunch of money
from this thing that was so impossible
to predict that that's how this whole
thing would pay off right mom I know
yeah yeah I don't have health insurance
I don't have a job I know I'm kind of
filming this like failing League this is
like lacrosse thing it's like
and it leads to the thing right so it's
a Steve Jobs I mean look back you see
all the dots how they connected but like
when you go even further back like and
the way this happened was my first idea
when I was 21 was to set up a laptop and
make YouTube videos about lacrosse
commentating right like that was a bad
idea when you really you know you zoom
out but if you're into it like a lot of
creators ask me like how long does it
take to make it
on YouTube like how long does it take to
make it I'm sure entrepreneurs ask that
question too right or have that thought
in their head like how long is this
gonna take
um and I was like I always think it's
such a ridiculous question because I'm
like well what's your relationship to
making videos
do you wake up every morning and you
can't not do it like you're just like
all I can do is make videos then you
made it then yeah you made it and it
will there will be an outcome from that
there will be it will lead you somewhere
um but if you wake up and you're like
this sucks it's kind of what you were
saying it's like I'm doing X so I can
get to Y well the entrepreneurship
version is
um startups fail but Founders don't so
like
I moved to San Francisco in 2012 so
that's 10 years ago and I met a bunch of
people and we used to have like these
like underground founder like meetings
or like training tips and tricks and
being like yo what do I do this person I
need to fire them what do I say when I
fire them like basically there's a bunch
of CEOs being like I can't like tell my
team about this I can't tell my
customers about this I can't tell my
investors about this I can only tell you
guys yeah because you guys understand
and look unlike YouTube everybody who
was doing Stars design was like all
living in the same seven mile radius
City and so we would just all meet up
all the time and sure enough like as you
watch if you tracked that cohort it's
basically only two outcomes one is got
so burnt out from like the grind and
failure that they just stopped after
like you know three four years uh more
than five years they just like did that
company they're like screw this I'm
taking a job I'm moving back to
Connecticut and like I'm gonna live in a
low-cost place I'm gonna de-stress and
I'm gonna do that but everybody else who
stayed in the game won like literally
like almost like a hundred percent of my
friends who stayed in the game yeah and
some of them won in year two someone in
year five someone in year nine now we're
in like you're 11 or 12. people are
winning like now but like and it's kind
of like it feels like a really long time
like wow 12 years it's like yeah but we
all started this when we were 21 so like
you know yeah um okay we're mid 30s yeah
because we're 34 and Rich like you know
yeah it worked in the end it worked
right the 15-year Arc you get like a
then the odds flip from like 90 of new
businesses failed to actually like 90 of
you guys will succeed if you actually
enjoy this enough where you'll keep
doing this even though you have easier
options yes I always I've said that
multiple times
um whenever I'm having something that
feels like I'm struggling I'm like this
is the uh uh the least rational path to
making money right is what I do that I
at this point also now I have enough
exposure and enough of an abundance in
my network that I can go and get it get
a good job right but like I do this
because it's
it's just what I do it's just who I am I
don't even know what to do in another
context I don't know what that looks
like I I will say though like being it's
hard to be uh not outcome oriented you
know like I think as an entrepreneur
you'd think about like exits and you
think about you know like these big
paydays and uh I would say that even
with with our newsletter like when I saw
milk road I was like okay I want that
outcome too but whenever I get too
attached to that outcome I'm like okay
wait a second right that that's like
that's creating in a way that's just
like the product probably will not be
great if I don't just put my head down
and go okay it's Mondays this Monday
issue really great okay it's Wednesday
so this Wednesday issue really great and
I've really tried to
um refine my focus on process and impact
like is I I have to focus on the process
of creating the thing and then the
second thing is like my a lot of my
reward is seeing if we're having impact
is is this actually impactful what I'm
putting out right or is it just going
out and you know no one's saying
anything about it or we're not getting
any like I I find I gauge the success of
our stuff from like the texts I get or
the DMS or like hey that episode is
really impactful or hey that really
changed the way I think about this or
hey that newsletter taught me about this
if I see those that I'm like okay we're
doing we're doing something
um let's keep doing that and hopefully
that takes us to an outcome but you also
have to accept it might not it might
just be this and we might just get you
know five percent better you know over
the next two years right and that's it
and you have to accept that that is a
that is the maybe the most likely
reality is that you just keep doing it
right and as long as you can accept that
it's for me that's how I I you know
explore it for myself yeah the best test
of a project is basically would we
regret doing it if it didn't work right
like obviously we don't want it not to
work and we might be upset if it didn't
work but like would we actually regret
doing it if it didn't work because then
it's like oh I'm just actually dependent
on the success or failure of what's
usually a low odds of success Endeavor
totally whereas other things you're like
oh really regret it because I well I'm
still gonna get this like still gonna be
fun to do still gonna learn a ton I'm
like this is the type of thing I like to
do yeah so you know if this doesn't work
out it doesn't really matter like I'm
just gonna ping pong to the kind of the
next version of this but it was a
forward it was a forward step either way
right like there's this uh uh like Tony
Robbins does this thing where he does
this
um dabblers versus Masters I don't know
if you've ever heard this so he tells a
story at his events where he goes um
he goes uh there's some people that they
go and they discover racquetball which
maybe now pickleball would be the shirt
but it's like you know they go they go
to the gym they're like they see
somebody playing racquetball they're
like oh try it they go and they have
they have some fun and they're like
racquetball this might be my thing and
they're like okay I'm gonna play
racquetball and so they the next day
they come back play again next day they
actually go and they uh you know they
get better shoes because they're like oh
that was the problem last time they buy
the racket they start playing blah blah
blah and they they're doing well but
then they play somebody who's been
playing for like 10 years
who's like way better than them and
that's you know for three days straight
they're playing and they can't hit a
good shot everything's going off and
they're losing all these games and
they're like this stupid like stupid
racquetball like right I mean this box
I'm trapped like you know this is it's
too loud in here it is weird this is a
sport for old people you start to find
all these Reasons to Quit so they they
quit like I'm gonna play real game I'm
gonna go play uh tennis so go outside
you play tennis you're like oh so much
better on my doors this is way better
and you know you're hitting the ball
around they're starting to learn The
Strokes they're enjoying learning a
little bit
same thing happens they start to play
somebody who knows what's going on
they're hitting the ball in the net they
can't really serve well that's it's
getting frustrating it's hot out and
they're like stupid game like you know
what is this this is this is like a
girly game I don't want to play it I
want to play like a real game
Golf and they're like just [__]
and he's basically like you know most
people go through their whole life doing
a series of these dabbling and they're
dabblers and he's like what's the
difference between a mast there's like
there's three categories a dabbler a
dabbler is basically like try it as soon
as it gets hard bounce then he's like
then there's the stressor achiever
stressor Achievers like when it gets
hard they just start gritting their
teeth and they just gonna keep going but
they don't enjoy any of it and like all
the hardship stresses them out but
they've just been trained since they're
a little kid to like push through it
just keep pushing through and like
you'll get a gold star later like the
The Joy will be later he's like then
there's the master the master is
basically like they like they know that
when you start something new there's the
initial like Joy of Discovery there's
the learning curve there's the hard
plateaus and when the plateau comes they
greet it like an old friend like oh
there you are like I thought you'd be
showing up soon I've been right I've
been playing for a week and usually
that's when I'll hit that's when you
arrive plateau and I know how to like
deal with you because I know that after
the plateau comes the next uprise and
I'm excited for that upswing but yeah
let me work through this Plateau they
don't really get like flustered by it so
they get the same or they get better
results than all three way better than
the dabbler significantly better than
the stressor achiever but the difference
is like the whole way
they're kind of actually like enjoying
the dance or playing the game yeah
because they actually understand that
this is like these are all normal for
the game and you find that like the
people who um
get really like into like struggling or
grinding or like get really overwhelmed
by like you know the adversity it's
really just like you haven't played the
game enough to know that this is no this
is how the levels of the game work yeah
you shouldn't be surprised that the
roller coaster is going up and down like
yeah you remember you got on the you got
in line to get on a roller coaster right
that's a good point you know one thing
that uh I don't know why this made me
think of it I think just because like
the ups and downs of the game and the
conversation we were having at the
beginning of the show about interviewing
one thing that both Colin and I did was
go to improv class to learn how to be to
get better yeah just to get better at
like being present working with whatever
the other person says like what we found
was my wife was listening to our
interviews and she was like you're not
listening to them you're just not
listening to your guests they're saying
something and then you say something
completely different you're just waiting
you're just waiting to talk and so I
went to improv class and it was really
this incredible uh lesson in the craft
of how do you sit in the pocket and just
be like I can't have any
preconceived notions as to where this is
about to go right you're going to say
something and I have to let go of where
I want it to go right I found myself in
the first day of improv I was like we
were playing this game and I was like
okay I know exactly how to make this
funny this is going to be funny I know
where to take it and the person right
before me said something and I was like
why the hell would you say that and then
I had to deal with it and then I was
like oh this is the work right this is
the craft or building the craft and I
think
you know in in in the the roller coaster
of being a podcaster like you have to be
willing to do all of that in public as
well right right like you you go back
and you watch your early episodes that
roller coaster is there's a record of
the roller coaster of like times where
it was going really well times where it
wasn't going well times reviews were up
times where views were down it's like
all public and I think um
it's it's challenging because we have to
practice in public I think that's like
as as you build in public as an
entrepreneur but if something incredibly
just you're like naked as a content
creator out there everyone can see
everything so well you guys are doing an
amazing job I'm a fan thank you I look
forward to kind of seeing if this is
your kind of like learning phase then
like you know I'm excited to see what
it's like as you guys Master this so
appreciate it thanks for uh thanks for
doing this I really appreciate it thank
you so much
[Music]
foreign